وانتقل الى مؤمن شرافي والموجود في خان
يونس الذي سقط فيها اليوم عشره شهداء
حدثنا عن الاستهداف لخان يونس
اليوم نعم ليلى ارتفع عدد الشهداء الذين
ارتقوا جراء تواصل الغرات والقصف المدفعي
الاسرائيلي على مختلف المناطق في مدينه
خانيونس الى 14 شهيدا حتى هذه اللحظه قبل
قليل طائرات مسيره اسرائيليه اطلقت
نيرانها وبشكل كثيف تجاه عدد من النازحين
داخل مستشفى الامل التابع لجمعيه الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني ما ادى الى وقوع عدد من
الاصابات في صفوف النازحين هذا المستشفى
ومباني جمعيه الهلال الاحمر في حي الامل
تؤوي الالاف من النازحين من سكان مدينه
غزه وايضا من سكان مناطق متفرقه من مدينه
خان يونس الذين اجبروا على النزوح والدخول
الى داخل اسوار هذا المستشفى والاحتماء
بمباني جمعيه الهلال الاحمر الاسرائيلي من
الصواريخ والقذائف
الاسرائيليه التي لا تتوقف على مدار
الساعه هنا في مدينه خانيونس ايضا قبل
قليل تم انتشال جثامين ثلاثه من الشهداء
من منطقه قيزان النجار بالاضافه الى قصف
اسرائيلي استهدف مجموعه من المواطنين قرب
مجمع مدارس العوده في منطقه عبسان شرق
مدينه خان يونس ما ادى الى ارتقاء شهيدين
ووصول عدد من الاصابات الشهداء والاصابات
في منطقه عبسم لا تستطيع طواقم الاسعاف
الوصول اليهم ونقلهم الى المشفى الاوروبي
القريب القريب من تلك المنطقه بالاضافه
الى ان النازحين يضطرون الى دفن جثامين
الشهداء داخل هذه المدارس التي تضم نحو
4000 نازح سبعه شهداء تم دفنهم داخل مدارس
العوده في منطقه عبسان من بينهم سيدتان
منذ اربعه ايام وصلتنا مناشدات من تلك
المنطقه منذ اربع ايام لم تصل لا مساعدات
غذائيه ولا ولا ايضا طبيه من قبل الصليب
الاحمر الى نحو 7000 نازح داخل هذه
المدارس يناشدون الصليب الاحمر بضروره فتح
ممر انساني لادخال المساعدات والمعونات
الغذائيه والطبيه اليهم لا يوجد في ثلاث
مدارس تضم 7000 نازح سوى طبيب واحد يعمل
بجهود محدوده جدا لعلاج الجرحى الذين
يصابون نتيجه القصف الاسرائيلي المستمر
على منطقه عبسان حيث تدور اشتباكات في
المحور الجنوبي من منطقه عبسان بين
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بالاضافه الى الاجزاء الشرقيه
والشماليه من منطقه بني سهيله وايضا في
منطقه قيزان النجار حيث ان تدور هناك
اشتباكات ضاريه بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تحديدا في محيط
منطقه كليه الع العلوم التكنولوجيه
بالاضافه الى القصف المدفع الكثيف في وسط
مدينه خان يونس والاشتباكات التي تدور في
منطقه البلد على مقربه هنا من مجمع مصلا
ال طبيه اشكرك مؤمن على هذه التفاصيل